H: Good Morning John!
J: Wait where do I stand? Here?
H:Yeah you know.
J: I seem a little dark.
H: I look great!
J: We switch places, I bet you'll look a little dark.
H: Come on more CML! You know.
J: We're here in Los Angeles together for the DFTBA.com annual meeting.
H: Yeah we're talking to all the people who helped make that website work.
J: If you need T-Shirts, posters, mugs, plushys, key-chains? Check out DFTBA.com
J: I'm a little concerned that you might be graying a little bit in the temples.
J: Now I know that I am all... I'm full grey.
H: You are not in any way full grey!
J: I'm the oldest youtuber.
H: No.
J: I am the last living American youtuber.
H:You are the last living American.
H: You know a true thing John?
J: Yes.
H: We talked about on an episode of Dear Hank & John in the past, about-
J: That's our podcast
H: about how there were only two possible multiverse futures in which Donald Trump became the republican nominee.
H: And in one of them...
J: We're living in the worst time I ...
H: And in one of them, it was because a meteor killed all but 12 Americans.
H: But he still wasn't elected President.
H: Alright John
H: We got some questions from people!
H: I've got questions from Snapchat.
J: They "snatted" (Snapchat + Chatting) their questions?
H: They "snatted" to me some questions!
J: And now we shall answer them!
H: This question is
"What is your favourite form of the potato?
J: Oh God!
J: Are we doing potatoes again?!
H: No.
H: That was. I did not ask for potatoes!
H: This is completely unrelated.
J: My strongly... I have a strong  preference for "French Fries".
H: The next question is
H: I don't know how to work my phone!
"Do you like snapchat filters?"
J: I'm going to level with you.
J: I don't know how to use snapchat very well.
J: But when I was in Jordan
J: Our interpreter "Nida" sat down with kids and used snapchat filters.
J: And they were crazy about them.
J: I mean they were laughing, they were screaming, they couldn't believe it.
J: And then I sat down next to them
J:  And I was like, "Actually this is pretty amazing!"
H: "How cute is this cat?"
J: On a scale of like 1 to 10.
J: I'm going to say 8.
H: Yeah it's a pretty cute cat.
H: "Who would win in a fight? Andrew Jackshon or Seodore Roosevelt?"
J: Can you just say that right?
H: "Who would win in a fight Andrew Jackshon..."
H: Who would... (laughs)
H: "Should this young woman condition or shampoo first?"
J: Oh, always shampoo then condition!
H: I never have heard of conditioning first!
J: I didn't even know that conditioning first was an option!
H: You just going to wash out all the condition..ment.
J: This nerdfighter asked ...
J: "Would vlogbrothers ever do a tour?"
H: Funny you should ask!
H: Because I'm announcing "Hank and the perfect Strangers Tour" today!
H: Right now!
H: It's happening!
J: Really!
H: I just announced it!
J: Wow! Where you're guys all going?
H: We're going to all of these places!
H: There! I didn't have to remember.
J: Great!
H: That was great!
J: But you can also look at the link in the description about the tickets and stuff.
H: Yeah all the tickets are available now
H: And they're inexpensive because we're not that popular!
J: And then Hank and I will hopefully go on tour sometime next year together.
H: "What's your favourite food to eat when you're sick?"
J: You know Hank it's an old favourite, and I know a lot of people feel this way.
J: But I just really enjoy "Chloraseptic Max"
H: Oh yeah, high calorie!
J: Ah, that goes right into the back of the throat, where the strep is. And it just makes it not hurt.
H: It smells like a Doctor's office.
H: "Favourite Taylor Swift song?"
J: We're going to do it on three.
J: Ready?
J: 1...  2... 3!
J & H: Shake it off!
J: Oh my god! We should be brothers!
H: "How goes the book writing John?
J: Oh, thanks for asking, woman with angler fish!
J: It's going. I'm writing.
H: What word are you on?
J: Um, you mean the last word that I wrote?
J: I'll look!
H: You found it?
J: I found the word!
J: The word is coffee
H: Ah I know a little bit about your book!
J: It includes stirring milk into morning coffee, no less.
H: Oh do you think that line is going to make it?
J: Um - 50/50?
H: All right, got another question, John...
H: "Can you show us your socks?"
J: Yes!
H: "If you were a kitchen appliance what would you be?"
J: I'd be a toaster-oven.
J: You want to ask why?
H: Not really.
J: Well there is really no reason. I just love toaster-ovens.
H: I'd be an oven.
H: Because I'm reliable, and I'm hot.
H: You are reliable, hot, and inexpensive.
J: That's right.
(John coughing)
H: Very sorry, you're so sick right now.
J: Oh well Hank I'll see you on ...  [coughs]